[Music]
whatever happened here they want to hide
it
they can't hide it from me
who are you Rachel
what'd you see
we should not have come to Metropolis
[Applause]
the Temple of azeratus now yours welcome
to the ancient world Mr Luther
soon the gods will know your name
I can assure you the gods already know
me
this is Lex Luthor I'd like to meet in
person
[Applause]
he's the only man Bruce Wayne was ever
afraid of
Superman's not afraid of him neither am
I you should be we're dealing with the
supernatural that scares me my name is
jinx and this is the person we're going
to for help good Magic versus Batman
Dick Grayson deal maker extraordinaire
podcast okay I don't know whatever all
this is but we do need your help
the world is a brutal place we're all so
alone what are you doing
Sebastian I know what's in your heart
who the hell are you it's just a hunch
but I'm gonna assume she's a bad guy
ever since we got to Metropolis strange
things have been happening to me if I
try and tell me something I can hear
everything that people here say about me
they will never let me forget what I am
my father likes him you're a part of our
family and if you leave it's gonna hurt
us
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]